hey travis tammy here big
fan i think you had some of the best
music videos of the 90s
i think your performance in your video
tell me i was dreaming
should have won an oscar my question to
you is i know you've done a lot of
acting
in your career which do you prefer
full-time rock star
or full-time movie star love you
i love you too that's a good question
man because at certain points of
of popularity they start to offer you
things that they might not have offered
you you don't have to go into that room
to audition as much
that's exactly man i had no aspirations
whatsoever about being an actor
right but did it grow on you though well
i enjoyed it and i'll tell you the
reason why
um i was always
out of my element when i was doing a
movie or a television show or whatever
it may be
when i was doing any kind of acting
and so because i was so insecure about
it and so nervous about it
i didn't just go in and learn my lines i
learned the whole damn script
i knew everybody's lying and um
because i'm i have a real hard time
multitasking i
i get real laser focused on whatever it
is i'm doing at the moment
so if i'm songwriting i'm focused on
that if i'm recording i'm
really focused on that and if i'm
performing i'm really
focused on that so doing
these acting roles it forced me to
concentrate so much on that that i
completely
took a vacation from music i didn't
think about music i didn't talk about
music i didn't
uh try to write music or whatever and i
found that the benefit of that
was when i finished a acting role
and came back to the music i found that
i was more creative
um it was like man this is a fresh start
again
yeah and um i wrote better songs
um i performed better my mind was more
in the game
because if you do anything i think over
a long period of time same thing over
and over again
it can tend to get a little bit
monotonous yeah but
if you get a break from it and then you
get a chance to come back and look at it
through a little bit different
perspective
uh it helped me tremendously i think it
helps make me a better
artist and and a better songwriter and
a better entertainer was there um
was there a role ever that you kind of
like oh this is kind of neat like
because acting one of the reasons that
people don't know acting if you're a
touring artist
acting takes a lot of time it's a really
long
so you know as a musician you could
probably do
six shows in a daytime of you would do
one set or one scene
or half an episode of a tv program or
something so
that's one of the reasons i think a lot
of uh entertainers don't
go over into acting that aren't actors
right um was there a role or something
you felt like you kind of got into or
something man
the one i had the most fun with was
i got to do do you remember a show
called tales from the crypt
yes yes i remember the beginning the
opening thing
yeah with galaxies exactly okay i got to
do
tales from the crypt with hank azaria
and with um ben stein
and i played we were robbing
um bodies for this
doctor so that he could try to find what
he believed was
the soul gland in a person
and at the end i'll
go ahead and give you a spoiler away
yeah there you go right there
i get my head cut off
and i come back from the dead am because
they didn't remove my soul gland
i come back from the dead and
that was so much fun because
there were no limitations on what the
director basically said
do whatever you want to do come up with
your own voice for it
act as crazy as you possibly can
do any wild stuff that you want to do
and this
your your parameters are just
wide open and that was so much fun man i
came up
you know i come out and of course i'm
i've got this head on backwards
and i'm i look like i'm with your head
yeah they did a they did a uh
todd masters who did all of the special
effects for that
show he created a head a rubber head of
me
it was perfect that they dropped down a
well and i come back out of the well
and man it was that was just so much
fun to do that particular role because
there were
you know it's always fun to play kind of
the bad guy yeah
you know that's always fun but but
especially when it's like you're this
monster that has
returned from the dead there's no
there's no limitations on that oh yeah
huh it's free free but it's all it's
it's open game yeah exactly yeah you're
already dead dude it's a wrap
i'd do whatever you want now hope you
enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one